بتعليق المشانق للمحتاجين يجابيه النظام
الايراني لاحتجاجات الشعبيه الايرانيه
المتصاعده للشهر الثالث على التوالي مجيد
رضا رحنا ورد هو الثاني بعد محسن شيكاري
الذي ينفذ فيه حكم الاعدام علنا في مدينه
مشهد شمال الشرقيه ايران لزعم قتله عنصرين
من قوى الامن الايراني زعموا السلطات
الايرانيه بخلفه اعدام ورد كان سبقه تهديد
صريح من قبل رئيس اللجنه القضائيه في
البرلمان الايراني الذي توعد المحتاجين
بزياده عمليات الاعدام بحقهم ما يمثل
دليلا اضافيا وفق منظمه العفو الدوليه على
استخدام السلطات لعقوبه الاعدام كاداه
كمان سياسي
منظمات حقوقيه اطلق التحذيرات بخصوص اعداد
من الايرانيين وصفاتهم بالمعرضين لخطر
الاعدام الوشيك المرتبط بالتظاهرات
قضاء النظام اعلن اذانه احد عشر محتجا
بالاعدام حتى الان
لكننا نشطاء يقولون ان حوالي 12 اخرين
وجهون تهاما قد تؤدي الى تسليط عقوبه
الاعدام عليهم خاصه ان النظام الايراني
يستخدم عقوبه الاعدام كجزء من حمله القمع
الوحشي بحسب منظمه حقوق الانسان في ايران
ومقرها اوسلو التي وثقت اسماء
458 شخصا على الاقل قالت انهم قتلوا على
ايدي قوات النظام فيما تشير الامم المتحده
الى ان ما لا يقل عن 14,000 شخص معتقلون
على خلفيه التظاهر لدى سلطات طهران حنان
المصري العربيه